okay so we're now we are now we have a
small army of people that are coming to
help us and out Pizza Pizza Hut has
donated a bunch of pizza and we're
handing up heat so to the people who are
in the comic online right now I think
we've got quite a few pizzas heading our
way and watch out and we're right now
walking sort of through the mouth of the
Dragon in gas town in San Diego this is
sort of where everybody hangs out at
night at Comic Con getting drunk and
dressing up and doing [ __ ] like that
we're gonna go deliver these pizzas I've
got a bunch of about volunteers from
random acts which is the nonprofit that
I work with and that helped found and
they're gonna hand out pizzas with me
and then what else can I tell you
also since you guys are Dane spot I have
a game that I want to tell you about
high five greatest international
scavenger hunt the world has ever seen
and registration for that closes in
about a week it is truly the best
scavenger hunt in the world tens of
thousands of people participate we have
eight Guinness World Records it's super
fun so if you want to sign up and join
in go to dish was calm we're gonna
circle up in front of a truck full of
pizza and hand it out soon meet us there
do it holy [ __ ] dude